President Trump says he's working on a
way to bypass a Supreme Court ruling and
at a citizenship question to the 2020
census after week a back and forth and a
decision deadline that has now come and
gone the Justice Department said Friday
it is still looking for a legal way to
include the question on the survey mr.
Trump is spending the weekend at his
Golf Resort in Bedminster New Jersey and
Nicole Killian is traveling with the
president Nicole good morning good
morning to you Jeff President Trump says
his administration is looking at this
very seriously and has several options
at its disposal including an executive
order as he looked the White House for
his new jersey Golf Club for the weekend
President Trump set off a new
controversy over the 2020 census the
president confirmed he is considering an
executive order to include a question on
citizenship after the Supreme Court
blocked the administration from doing it
last month and that's not the only idea
under consideration
Friday the Justice Department told a
federal judge it's continuing to look
for legal grounds but earlier this week
the agency along with the Commerce
Department indicated it would move
forward without the question printing
has already started on the government
survey taken every 10 years to determine
everything from federal funding to seats
in Congress opponents say the
citizenship question is being used as a
political tool if we don't take it we're
gonna lose a lot of support for the our
communities in our region's immigrant
advocates also rallied in Washington
Friday with calls to abolish ice
the president said deportation roundups
would start fairly soon to remove
undocumented immigrants well I don't
call them raids I say they came in it
and we're bringing him out legally he
also defended conditions at migrant
detention centers along the southern
border following an internal watchdog
report that described a ticking time
bomb at some facilities including
overcrowding and a lack of hot meals
I've seen some of those places and they
are run beautifully all this comes as a
second secret Facebook page made up of
Customs and Border Patrol employees has
been discovered much like the first aid
MUX migrants and some members of
Congress President Trump says he hasn't
seen it
CBP says it's investigating tarika
nicole thank you